lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducir el concepto de conjunto
universal o universo de referencia para
nuestros conjuntos y también el concepto
de complemento o complemento absoluto y
usando un diagrama de ven usualmente el
universo se representa como un
rectángulo es en sí mismo un conjunto
que se designa por la letra de universo
no confundir esto con el símbolo que
designa a la unión entre conjuntos y
podría considerarse el universo como el
conjunto de todos los posibles objetos
podríamos hablar de animales podríamos
hablar de personas podríamos hablar de
emociones podemos hablar de autos
podríamos hablar de países en fin hay
tantas cosas que puedan estar incluidas
en un conjunto universal pero eso es un
poco absurdo pensar en todas las cosas
posibles formalmente cuando hablamos de
un conjunto universal hablamos del
conjunto de objetos que nos interesa el
conjunto de personas el conjunto de
números reales el conjunto de animales
se usa un conjunto universal adecuado al
contexto de interés por el momento lo
consideraremos en términos abstractos
digamos que tenemos un subconjunto de
este conjunto universal
llamémosle conjunto a el cual contiene
todos los elementos en esta zona que
estoy marcando ahora podemos introducir
el concepto del complemento de a o
complemento absoluto del conjunto a y
este conjunto lo podemos definir como el
conjunto de todos los objetos
que están en eeuu y que no están en el
conjunto
y ya hemos visto que el conjunto de
todos los objetos que están en un y que
no están en a también lo podemos
escribir como o menos y se insiste no
confundir está mayúscula con el símbolo
de unión entre conjuntos y esto también
se puede escribir como y está diagonal
invertida que hemos denominado slash
y como representamos esto en el diagrama
de ven bueno estamos hablando de todo lo
que pertenece al universo todos los
elementos del universo que no están en
todos los eventos del universo que no
están en una manera de ver esto también
es el complemento relativo de a con
respecto a un aunque en realidad estamos
hablando del complemento absoluto en
general cuando se habla del complemento
se habla de los elementos que están en
un y que no están en a vamos a aclarar
esto usando conjuntos numéricos aunque
de nueva cuenta se insiste que podíamos
usar conjuntos de personas de animales
de automóviles cualquier tipo de objetos
aunque el conjunto de números es el más
fácil de usar digamos entonces que
nuestro universo el universo que estoy
poniendo aquí consiste en el conjunto de
números enteros así que nuestro universo
es el conjunto de los enteros lo va a
poner aquí el universo es igual y por
cierto el conjunto de los enteros se
designa con esta letra zeta en lo que se
denomina tipografía de negrita de
pizarra esta letra zeta
al número en alemán es la que designa a
los números enteros todos los conjuntos
numéricos se designan por letras en esta
tipografía negrita de pixar yo voy a
poner una nota al margen para aclarar la
anotación de los conjuntos numéricos la
r negrita pizarra designa a los números
reales luego para los racionales se usa
esta q en esa tipografía que hemos dicho
de negrita de pizarra
así que cu cú para el conjunto de los
números racionales y porque q bueno hay
un par de razones por un lado la r ya se
usó para reales y por otro lado viene el
inglés scott send que significa
consciente o razón entre dos números y
como ya vimos tenemos la z la zeta de
sol para los enteros
la zeta que representa el conjunto de
los números enteros
así es que nuestro universo es el
conjunto de los números enteros y
pongamos un conjunto déjame usar una
letra que no usado aún que no usado
mucho aún pongamos el conjunto se
llamemos el conjunto c que consta de los
números menos 50
y 7 este es nuestro conjunto vamos a
dibujarlo aquí el conjunto de los
enteros un conjunto infinito y vamos a
poner aquí
este conjunto finito que es el conjunto
ce este de aquí es el conjunto ce y
pensemos entonces cuáles son los
elementos de c y cuáles no son los
elementos de c para empezar menos 5 es
un elemento o pertenece hace esta letra
de aquí significa que pertenece
significa pertenencia aunque parece la
letra épsilon griega es un símbolo
distinto este símbolo significa
pertenencia a un conjunto sabemos qué 0
pertenece al conjunto se hace no a 7
hace 0 pertenece a c y 7 también
pertenece a c también sabemos
por ejemplo -8 no pertenece al conjunto
ce también sabemos que 53 no pertenece
al conjunto que no pertenece al conjunto
ce por aquí en algún lugar se encuentra
el 53 y también que el 42 no pertenece
al conjunto ce quizá por aquí ubicamos
el 42 consideremos ahora cómo
representar el complemento de c o sea
complemento el complemento de c lo cual
equivale a un menos lo cual es lo mismo
que el complemento relativo de c en
estas de aquí
las tres son notaciones equivalentes y
como representamos esto en el diagrama
deben bueno esto de esta zona en el
universo que está fuera de c que no
abarca c y si tenemos que menos 5
pertenece hace entonces menos 5 menos 5
pertenece a ese complemento pero no
pertenece a ese complemento 0 se ubica
en ce no ese complemento
ahora bien 53 pertenece a ese
complemento se ubica fuera de ese se
encuentra en el universo pero fuera de
ese 42 pertenece al complemento de c en
fin espero que te haya quedado claro lo
que hemos visto en este vídeo